non
ou pas
à
[Musique]
ma grand mère avait raison le
croquemitaine et qui s'est terminée elle
ne pourra plus faire de mal à personne
personne ne vous a rien dit personne me
dit quoi
il ya quelqu'un là dedans
[Musique]
michael myers est en vie
arrêtes tu t'es pris un couteau dans le
ventre toi et alison vous ne devriez pas
avoir à continuer à fuir le mâle meurs
ce soir
[Musique]
je vais pas rester les bras croisés en
attendant titude autres me sens quand on
regarde où michael de frapper votre sim
mines qui mène droit sam et son enfance
on fait quoi mais on la france
on va l'hydrater
michael mayer s'est fait de chair et de
sang
et aucun homme
rubis survivre à cet assaut
mais tu oui il se transcende
c'est le mal incarné
[Musique]
m
tu peux ton masque
karcher ton heure est venue michael
[Musique]